pensemos un poco en la molécula de
cloruro de sodio
si observamos la tabla periódica que
tengo justo aquí el sodio es un elemento
del grupo 1
un metal alcalino tiene un electrón de
valencia no es muy electro negativo
porque además la electro negatividad de
los elementos incrementa desde abajo
hacia arriba y de la izquierda hacia la
derecha
de esta manera estos son los elementos
más electro negativos mientras que estos
donan más sus electrones son electro
positivos y estos son electro negativos
entonces el sodio tiene un electrón de
valencia es un buen candidato para donar
su electrón y del otro lado de la tabla
periódica tenemos al cloro está en el
grupo 7 de los elementos es una halógeno
lo que más ama en el mundo es ganar un
electrón porque cuando el cloro gana un
electrón al tener 7 electrones gana un
electrón que le da un total de 8 y ese
número 8 es el número mágico el mágico
número del octeto 8 electrones de
valencia así que es muy electro negativo
como se imaginan que interactúan estos
dos elementos el cloro tomará el
electrón del sodio y se convertirá en el
anio floruro y el sodio se convertirá en
un camión el camión es un ión positivo
mientras que el avión es un ión negativo
entonces esto es posible el sodio es
positivo y el cloro es negativo se
atraen entre sí y forman un enlace
iónico este es un enlace
iónico
enlace iónico ahora veamos algo que no
sea iónico es decir que los electrones
no sean donados completamente de un
átomo a otro pero sí que estén
compartidos bueno uno de los ejemplos
más famosos es el agua h2o cada molécula
de agua tiene un oxígeno
unido a dos hidrógenos
y estos enlaces son covalentes en cada
enlace tenemos un par de electrones que
se comparten entre el hidrógeno y el
oxígeno pero sabemos que no los
comparten equitativamente si observan la
tabla periódica el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno así
que los electrones en ambos enlaces
estarán más con el oxígeno que con los
hidrógenos esto le dará al oxígeno una
carga parcial negativa y a los
hidrógenos una carga parcial positiva
esta es la realidad a veces no es
conveniente mostrar las cargas parciales
lo que haré es mostrarles una gran
herramienta fue inventada por químicos
pensando en las reacciones químicas esa
herramienta es el estado de oxidación
estado de oxidación
el estado de oxidación se puede aplicar
incluso en un enlace covalente quizá
estén pensando ok entiendo que estas son
las cargas parciales y estos son los
enlaces covalentes pero no me gustan las
cargas parciales podemos suponer en la
sesión y cos claro que si en este caso
el oxígeno tomaría todos los electrones
eso le da una carga formal negativa una
carga formal
2 - y cada uno de los hidrógenos tendría
una carga formal positiva entonces si
escribimos los estados de oxidación para
cada átomo de la molécula de agua
tenemos h 2
el oxígeno tiene una carga 2 - y cada
hidrógeno tiene una carga de 1 más
observen que toda la molécula es neutral
estas cargas se cancelan con esta 11 nos
da una carga 2 positiva que se cancela
con esta carga 2 negativa algo
importante que les quiero mencionar es
que la carga se escribe después del
valor numérico pero si queremos escribir
un estado de oxidación de 1 entonces
solamente escribimos la carga y así se
sabe que la carga es igual a 1 por
ejemplo 1 positivo para los hidrógenos
simplemente se escribe el signo y así se
sabe que la carga es igual a 1
entonces si escriben las cargas iónicas
o los estados de oxidación para el caso
en el que tuvieran que expresar una
molécula sin los enlaces covalentes
pueden usarlos en la sesión y coss pero
recuerden esta es la realidad son
enlaces covalentes y cargas parciales
el estado de oxidación nos permite
expresar lo con enlaces iónicos espero
que tenga sentido para ustedes y aquí se
involucra al oxígeno por eso se llaman
estados de oxidación o al menos así lo
relacioné cuando escuché esto por
primera vez en este caso podemos decir
que como cada hidrógeno perdió un
electrón que el oxígeno gana entonces
los hidrógenos son oxidados por el
oxígeno
el hidrógeno es oxidado por el oxígeno
y el otro término es el de reducción
como la carga del oxígeno fue reducida
por eso se dice que el oxígeno
fue reducido fue reducido
por los hidrógenos
y aquí podemos ver nuevamente la
influencia del oxígeno pero no siempre
habrá un oxígeno involucrado veamos otro
ejemplo
digamos que tenemos ácido fluorhídrico
en solución acuosa entonces tenemos un
hidrógeno unido covalente mente al flúor
así como con el agua ahora el flúor es
el elemento más electro negativo así que
tendrá a los electrones cerca de él
tiene una carga parcial negativa y eso
hace que el hidrógeno tenga una carga
parcial positiva ahora si lo queremos
expresar en términos de estados de
oxidación cuáles son las cargas para
estos átomos bueno en el caso del
hidrógeno como pierde un electrón
entonces tiene una carga formal positiva
y el flúor al ganar un electrón tiene
una carga forma negativa es una
suposición teórica porque la realidad es
que tienen cargas parciales y un enlace
covalente
pero en esta suposición también podemos
decir que el estado de oxidación del
hidrógeno es de 1 positivo y el del
flúor es de 1 negativo el hidrógeno fue
oxidado por el flúor
y el flúor fue reducido
ahora podrían decirme hey espera estamos
usando la palabra oxidada y no hay un
oxígeno por aquí bueno como les decía es
una manera en que yo lo relacione la
palabra oxidación me recuerda mucho a un
oxígeno y a lo que hace un oxígeno al
oxidar a algún otro elemento pero no
necesariamente tiene que haber un
oxígeno para que haya una oxidación es
como los lentes de sol no es que los
lentes estén hechos de sol ni
necesariamente tenemos que usarlos
únicamente cuando hay sol otro ejemplo
es cuando se van de vacaciones si salen
de vacaciones a la playa y les dicen que
parecen peces en el agua no es que se
conviertan en peces al estar en el agua
pero al estar en el agua actúan lo más
parecido a un pez en el agua es lo mismo
que el flúor hizo con el hidrógeno no
tuvo que ser un oxígeno para poder
oxidar lo
hizo lo que haría el oxígeno tomar un
electrón y oxidada al hidrógeno por eso
lo relacione así si algo es oxidado
entonces pierde un electrón ya sea por
causa de un oxígeno o alguien que actúe
parecido el oxígeno es muy electro
negativo le gusta tomar electrones de
otros átomos si les cuesta trabajo
pueden usar la técnica de la mnemotecnia
es muy útil se trata de sintetizar un
montón de información en pocas letras
como por ejemplo gerpe o
here
significa que gana un electrón algo que
es reducido y pierde un electrón algo
que es oxidado
esa es una mnemotecnia o también está la
de rewe red
la reducción es ganar electrones y
oxidación es perder electrones